[Music]
good morning good morn
whoa i just faced reveal this is uh
no actually this is another filter
that's right there is a lot of changes
on this world
uh isn't that right dimitri
the thing is i recorded myself doing it
but it's so goddamn boring
to watch someone build i don't know how
to make it you're again
i kiss you what are you doing up here
let me just show you the fun stuff
what i made instead that's more fun
right uh this loud and noisy
annoying noise annoys noise it's because
i forgot to turn it off this is an auto
smelter that i built
it is really nice basically how it works
is
you put in what you want to melt here it
goes into the hopper
the hopper then distributes it to the
furnaces same thing here but you put the
coal
the coal gets distributed uh into the
furnaces
and then there's other hoppers
underneath goes here into the output
and bam you get a bunch of smelted stuff
really easily
very nice very cool not as cool as my
god church i will say
it's not as cool i was thinking about
building it here first and i'm like
nah nah i can't ruin my gun church it is
a little ruined to be hey
jurgen what you doing it is a little
ruined i'll i'll fix it
don't you worry uh what else have i done
i've done a lot of stuff
oh this is cool i built this railroad
system right but i
never used it because it was so annoying
with the
minecarts and stuff like that isn't that
right donkey i love you
he's a conductor he's a train conductor
so now i have an automated system
if i want to go outside i hit that
button one pops up
and i just go it works super well
i'm oh wait the game was muted my bad
guys
and yeah it just hits the cactus there's
a hopper underneath here
i didn't know you could do this it's
really cool actually like
you can make stuff go through the floor
into an item and then you hit the
redstone
it goes through a bunch of droppers into
the dispenser the dispenser dispenses it
and you're good to go
and i don't have to think about any of
the minecarts and stuff which uh
yeah this is really cool they're very
convenient uh it is a bit ugly with the
cactus i was trying to cover it up you
can't really oh
not that way but yeah this is really
good if i want to go to the mines
i go to the mines you know it's really
fast
it's so fast i'm outside the cart what
the [ __ ]
whoa we're back in gamers
and a bing bada boom bad bam i'm back
and i'm ready to mine uh-huh uh-huh i
love it
it's a small stuff all right i know it's
not important but i
like it okay i like it i don't know if
you can see on this face filter that i
have
uh my expressions work well but ah don't
[ __ ] with my redstone
um oh cleaned up the garden a little bit
i was testing out the terracotta over
here it looks
a bit out of place here but i think in
the house it'll look cool right dimitri
right the maidre they can't hear me
that's all right
god they're so loud you're so annoying
just
stop you're making my computer lag stop
it
will they live will you live will you
live will you live will you live
oh sad can they live my
nope all right okay let's stop stop that
now
oh god they're so annoying i'm going to
bed i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
i was demonstrating my redstone i will
go to bed
all right don bonkies monkey good night
gamer
good night yeah burn
let's go back to the exit and i'll show
you guys some more
oh thank you uh did i show this i can't
remember
i think i did yeah yeah so i built this
wall as well i
literally wasted all the iron that i
have i'll probably decorate it a little
bit but it look it looks pretty cool it
looks like i
live in a giant cage because i'm not
gonna die
uh-uh not gonna happen i'm safe in here
safe
and sound we still need to finish the
meatball my god
just finish the meatball before building
other stuff felix
okay i'm sorry um what else oh my god
yes this is
this is huge i finally sorted out my
villagers
oh i moved the beast by the way in case
uh in case you're worried about that
so yeah self-touch boom fortune 3 boom
we'll never i will never need it
uh blast protection boom efficiency boom
i will never need that again but
whatever mending i will need that many
times so yeah it's pretty cool
i've uh it was pretty easy to get them
in there usually what i do is i'll i'll
put them all
individually but it's way easier if you
have them all in one room and just wait
for them to go to their bench and
then you lock them in i made some
redstone i don't know if i could show
you
yeah i am trapped now [ __ ] oh wait i can
do this
why did i show you the redstone god damn
it
all right anyway uh there's a daylight
detector in there
and uh oh my god can you be quiet you're
so loud can i turn villagers down
friendly creatures my god okay oh that's
so nice i didn't realize i could do that
uh anyway shut up
when uh when it's night time these go up
so they're fully protected
i don't think anything can hit them
anyway but it's it's pretty cool
and clearly i forgot to invert the
signal here because it's doing the
opposite
why is it doing the opposite it's
working here
you're not a farmer but yeah we're gonna
make some stoics maybe i'll do that this
episode
got all my photographers so i can make a
lot of money now
like big money i'm talking big money
chichita bonita is the eve of this
playthrough she have birthed all these
children or haven't you chiquita
how you doing chiquita
[Music]
how are you how are you shikita you okay
you all right yeah
good good you should be proud
you should be proud dude you created so
many wonderful people
huh i kissed you for the first time
i showed my token appreciation a cactus
you're welcome you're welcome
um maybe i should move out the money i
could make a house out of emeralds
that's how rich i am i could make a
money out of money a house out of money
english is my first language thank you
i've just decided it's more
oh i did the thing i forgot i could do
it let's uh let's do some trading
i have actually these are all virgins
give me money give me money give me
money
is that a glitch where i can keep
trading even though it says x did you
notice that
i tried how much
xp that gives i probably should place
the staircase now that i think about it
what if i do this hack how much money
can i get
ah oh should give me better prices now
yeah give me the money give me the money
god damn all right let's trade with all
of them see how much i get
these guys have been working hard for me
this automatic farm is absolutely
amazing
oh holy [ __ ] it's still refilling itself
oh my gosh i actually don't know if they
will refresh yeah they do are you
already refreshed am i gone
let's get that snowings scythe do a
stoics montage
god damn i've literally left my computer
on every night
just so i can make strings
i wonder how much money that cost me in
an electricity bill i do have a problem
though which i have yet to solve
they are making bread why are you making
bread
oh cool sun is setting so now we can see
the redstone oh let me fix it really
quick then
wait what if i just open them shouldn't
they
i don't have to invert the signal i can
just open them
there you go they closed now okay so
that doesn't work okay fine
yeah it's sort of it's sort of it's a
work in progress okay
too bad you guys don't sleep though oh
they want to sleep maybe i should sleep
then
all right i'll sleep for you don't worry
i'm a good guy
all right uh let me fix you why are you
having problems
[ __ ] you can't escape there is no escape
villagers are very funny acting i don't
really understand like
they think doors are openings so this
guy thinks he can make it out alive
which he can't obviously oh my god
there's some stop stop
stop uh okay i'm gonna have to be fast
here
that's why he's not picking a profession
because he thinks he can escape
there you go give up on your dreams
i said give up on your dreams look
look yeah give up on your hopes and
dreams
i was that was not a voice crack that
was um uh too much manliness
[ __ ] [ __ ] this is the problem with too
strong
oh god
got you uh let's put a compost
stop trying to escape you will never
leave this place
what a troublemaker dude oh my god oh my
god
no no no no
no bad villager bad villager all right
here
[Music]
i hate villagers so much but they make
me money
it's all right see he became a farmer
now no he became he wanted to become a
fisherman because of the barrels
that is adorable which will never happen
you are meant to be farmer nothing else
ah this axe is too strong oh
god all right where did the farmer go he
should be up here right
see this guy this guy gave up why can't
the other guy give up
where is he you're not a fisherman
these are decorative barrels
stop it all right here i'll entice him
you want to be a farmer yeah i knew you
wanted to be a farmer [ __ ]
hey hey you want to be a farmer
you want to be a farmer don't you hey
you want to be a farmer over here
oh wow that's so cool previously i would
always move them in boats but it's way
easier to do it this way
it'll be a farmer oh come come little
farmer man
oh well look at you you became farmer
i'm so proud of you you wanna be a
farmer here
[ __ ] you honestly [ __ ] you
you saw through my track do you want to
be a farmer oh look
oh now you're a wannabe farmer god
they're so
dumb you know it's at some point it will
be easier for me to just kill you and
make another one of you right you
underst
you understand that concept right oh
yeah
that's a good farmer become a farmer in
here
oh no no no stay in there stay in there
stay in there done it is done
you will never escape this place you
farm here now
oh he became a all right
you give him a little shove and then
boom you're in you could have been
greatness
you could have been a farmer but now
lucky
go get the money go get the money see
yeah now they trade melon for really
good prices
i'm sure there's a way to make an
automatic melon farm
they are too good at making potatoes
they must be irish
what's the best item you can buy in
minecraft as
uh i mean i know mending and like books
and stuff but
i haven't done any of the other ones and
i actually don't know are they really
useful or not
because i was thinking about extending
these rows for like
random ones that i don't need as many of
i'm better at making money in minecraft
than anything else at this point
can't tell if sad are epic maybe i'll
build so all the items come down here
next to them how to
keep running back and forth oh they're
all close so you see that
that's kind of cool i think it's cool
but whatever
see i protect my villagers what i'm
doing isn't cruel at all
can you buy netherrite for example i
don't think i need it but that would be
cool
i don't know what to do with all this
money man i apparently started trading
and i've
already gotta get
50. i never been 50 i should probably
sleep
uh that was that was a hard day of of uh
trading i
better get a full night risk yeah
i think it's safe to say i need more
storage all right so that was just from
trading
a fifth of my inventory i would say and
i'm flexing how rich i am and that's
gonna offend some people i don't
normally do that but we're talking about
mike right here
all right let's go back home oh that's
nice
it says i'm high level now
now bonky i put them all bunk i guess
you can change them damn it
in case i lose my monkey i can get more
[ __ ]
uh bonky where my main ba
oh god where is monkey hey
you are my little one lover bonky
ah bunky you almost killed me ah stop
joke i can never die bonky
[Music]
all right so now that we got the gear we
got the money
we got the girl uh i think it's time we
go out
and do some motherflipping killing yeah
wouldn't i mention next question mark i
was supposed to go in my live stream
episode and then i got distracted from
all the
god damn i'm easily distracted i got
distracted
so much let's uh what are these potions
i should probably bring some potions
right
instant health instant health you can
make a potion of strength maybe i should
make that
yeah you just add blaze power so i can
either make it
stronger a lot or last longer so i think
may i'll make
one that lasts longer and one that's
more powerful so we got portion of
strength
so to make them more powerful you add
glowstone dust
and to make them last longer you add
redstone
plus six damage what does the sword do
in itself
11. so it does uh uh 17 damage then
damn that's a big boost you can probably
one shot a lot
okay i think i think we're good oh my
god it looks like a creeper blue up here
where's my map i had a map ocean
i lose it oh people said it was good to
bring a bell i'll bring a bell i'll
bring a leash
i'll bring a bow i can just buy another
map
goodbye donkey i'll make it out alive
oh that looks so sick i knew the fence
would be worth it
oh that's so cool whoa [ __ ] rainbow
if they
all right definitely let's not lose that
again
so the woodland is oh this is a
different one this is different than the
one i had the other one told me to go
north
so this one's telling me to go south
east i think south is that way
cool we'll get some different different
scenery
i'll go in the middle of the night i'm
not scared uh
goodbye meatball one day i'll finish you
i promise
um i did the wither recently with
some friends and it was a nightmare
it was an absolute nightmare i was
worried we weren't gonna be able to kill
him
and that was on regular difficulty i'm
like how the hell am i gonna do this on
hardcore i almost died so many times
but yeah i want to do all the stuff in
this play through
even though i i risk losing everything i
i want to do the dragon and i want to do
the weather and i want to do the
uh ocean exploring thing i mean kind of
holding it off just because i really
want to
become strong before going out and i
think
there's not much else for me to do at
this point except falling in like
falling in a random
don't say a goddamn word don't say a god
damn word
is there a thing i could actually go in
the boat if i follow right maybe i
should have a boat ready if i'm running
around
oh this is a death trap look at this
oh my gosh i am not a fan of the desert
am i going style yes i am if we're lucky
it's not too far away
but yeah it's going to be a long journey
i hope i can find a spruce forest
because i haven't done that look how
beautiful i love this
uh in a jungle i haven't found a jungle
either is that a jungle no that's a
swamp
surprisingly i found badlands before i
found spruce for us that's kind of crazy
maybe i should you know what maybe i
should sleep this is the this is a good
spot
i need to update my optifine i apologize
gamers
what's that miss me better luck next
time gamer
oh my god ah they're everywhere those
flowers are so pretty
and i go on the lily pads all the way
guys
look i'm dreaming [ __ ] look guys i'm
doing it
i'm doing it how does he do it [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
this i really need to speed up if i'm
gonna make it there
today but yeah if we do the woodland
mansion i hope to get a baby
so if i die i have some protection in my
off hand that would be nice another
death trap
nope
oh it's so satisfying hey sunflowers
that's so pretty oh get dunked on
hey they got jurgens here how's it going
jurgens
hey remember when i brought my dog all
the way to the woodland mansion
yeah that was a bad idea
how the hell did i do that i walked for
like three hours
i miss that dog i miss him greatly
is that a witch hut oh it is oh you're
laughing but i am
the one in the end that will laugh this
will be some good practice
what up [ __ ]
oh she has a cat
it just disappeared what
where'd it go the cat was evil and you
know it i'm getting swamp city here why
is there so many swamps
hey snow city kill one for the road
hey [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah nailed it dark forest
could this be it could that they're in
dark they're in the dark woods right
no i don't think this is it all right we
walked
3000 blocks there should be at least 5
000 more
oh god should i
oh god damn it guys
oh damn we're not getting closer i'll
tell you that
i'm starting to think that there is no
woodland mansion
because i ain't getting closer and i
walk 15 000 stabs
what the [ __ ] am i doing wrong hey guys
can i sleep with you
oh poor spidey yo
we got corals and [ __ ] dang it i don't
have any silk
touch oh they look so good
i love the corals oh my god yes
i can't i can't grab the cucumbers
though
i love how slimy they are on bedrock
corals is
so common but it's so rare on
java which is a shame because it's so
pretty i think they should add it more
dude this is massive oh god i forgot how
boring it is to find the woodland
mansion oh my god
hey death trap that wasn't so bad
oh [ __ ] got turtles give me the spruce
give me the juice
give me my shoes give me my
new oh my god i should have brought
bonky at least then i'd have a friend is
that a [ __ ]
yeah honestly i can't even be bothered
i just want the woodland maybe they have
a heart of the sea that'd be cool
oh it's sideways that's kind of cool
garbage i guess
man are you here
wait can't you see the gameplay oh my
god sorry guys
anyway spruce i found spruce support god
damn it
snow land actual snow oh it's ice
oh little bunny it's so cute there's a
scene from uh
last of us that's the cutest thing i've
ever seen in my life
don't run from me don't ever run from me
spanked
oh he's getting hunted by a polar bear
hey that was mine to kill how could you
yeah be ashamed of yourself all right
mother nature took its course
i'm glad bank has a baby i didn't know
it was a woman
i was a female version of banked
benny cool i'll i'll definitely come
back here
village oh so cool i haven't seen that
in a long time
i got little ice houses igloos they're
called
igloos felix okay that's a
motherflipping igloo
holy [ __ ] i found one
so there's this redstone here
i forgot what's special about eagle is
hey get back
back up back up there it is
hidden room ooh
exciting
so i guess here they're supposed to be
zombie here but it's invisible
you get a golden apple here uh i could
actually cure him now can i
you okay
oh
it's invisible what the hell
sorry man you're stuck down there very
confusing but
okay yes that's how ah
got bamboozled by snow all right gamers
i
will do the woodland mansion in the next
episode
yeah that's exciting smash like to make
sure i don't die
and i see you next time brofist
[Music]
diamonds